today's overlook review is actually one
of my favorite action movies of all time
I'm not kidding
I adore Broken Arrow and I don't care
what anybody says they are America's
first line of defense best of friends
are Calculon
after the earth here we go fierce
competitors very nicely done dr. voltar
goes insane and steals a nuclear warhead
ejects Christian Slater out of a jet
they are flying in together and starts a
humongous cat-and-mouse game for the
rest of the film see this movie falls
under a category that you might call a
guilty pleasure however I still think
it's directed really well by John Woo
he's very good with action this film's
got a lot of it carrying the nukes he
loved having the power of God at your
fingertips not tonight buddy but what if
the enemy is one of them hell are you
doing
we got pilots down
we got ourselves a broken arrow a broken
watch what we call it when we lose a
nuclear weapon I don't know what's
scarier losing nuclear weapons but that
happens so often there's actually a term
for it John Travolta's character is so
hilarious and just so entertaining
Christian Slater is a good hero I love
the dialogue they have with one another
I think the film is one of the most
underrated action movies ever made
I adore Broken Arrow I definitely think
if you have not seen Broken Arrow that
you should give it a chance and if maybe
you grew up with it or saw when you're a
kid like this movies about whatever
watch the widescreen cut of the film
look at the beautiful shots that are in
this movie there in two hundred and
fifty million dollars by oh nine hundred
Utah time if you have not
good god I don't know what the big deal
is I really don't but there's one thing
smile boys were about to retire he
didn't codons I know his mind works yeah
let me go after
outstanding hell that's the spirit
would you mind not shooting at the
thermonuclear weapons charge of Ulta is
total camp in this film and I adore it
I'm gonna get Broken Arrow three and a
half out of four stars I love it and I
don't care if you don't like it but in
my opinion it's a very overlooked film
and I think it deserves more of a chance
you know the wrong code three times and
it goes dead
unless of course I already thought about
ahead of time you just activated a
nuclear warhead my friend
the clock is ticking
here for a Coker Simpson
you lose Christian Slater you're out of
your mind
Ain't It Cool
a John Woo film